que pudieran imaginar,
que serán bienvenidos en cualquier sala de juntas,
o que pueden liderar cualquier empresa.
Esa idea de ser
la tierra de los libres y el hogar de valientes
es parte de la esencia de lo que es EE. UU.
En EE. UU. cuando tenemos un reto,
lo encaramos de frente, no nos escapamos.
Nos ponemos firmes. Mostramos coraje.
Así que ahora mismo, les pido que lo hagan:
les pido que muestren coraje.
Les pido que sean audaces.
Como líderes empresariales, les pido
que no dejen nada sobre la mesa.
Como ciudadanos, les pido no dejar ningún niño atrás.
Les estoy pidiendo que no sean ciegos al color,
que sean valientes frente al color,
para que todos los niños sepan que sus futuros
y sueños son posibles.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias. Gracias. (Aplausos)